Oui oui
Oui
je
et
Oui
soutes à charbon
autre
Oh
j'ai besoin de la batterie
il
à la vie
de telle manière
[Applaudissements]
ça valait le coup [ __ ]
mais non
Oui
si l'amour
bien
à présent
pour
lorsque
mais
de la vidéo
[Applaudissements]
et
et maintenant
Oui
et déjà
ré
à l'écossais
à présent
deux
mais
comme lui
[Musique]
rappelles toi
à moi
[Applaudissements]
Regardez, nous n'aurons pas à attendre et à voir car
veulent que
non
et
[Applaudissements]
ré
bon
[Applaudissements]
au contraire
comment il est
mes amours
et le
Oui
de la mine
Dans la zone
bien
jamais
Salut
seul
mettre
pour la vie
bon
mais regarde la mer
déjà
pas plus
Pizza
non
et maintenant
Oui
[Applaudissements]
m
et non
Oui
je
Eibar
et en réalité
[Applaudissements]
je
il y a plus
Oui
dans la vie
Oh
Oui
[Applaudissements]
mais non
bois mère
en plus d'avancer
de la sena
le regard
et
Oui
Voyons voir
ma mère n'arriverait pas
mais
ou non
du matin
et rien de plus
en réalité
un mensonge
tous les jours
nous serons avec tes amis
Merci beaucoup
je n'ai rien
pour cela
[Applaudissements]
Oh
et je vais
[Applaudissements]
deux
non non Non Non Non Non
non non Non
gouttes
s
nous ne pouvons pas trouver d'endroits pour manger
mais
favori
rien
ou non
et non
mais
Anglais
pour rien
Paris
plus que trois jours
réservation
[Musique]
cette qualité
avec lui
s
Salut
Yolande
et maintenant
Oui
je
de nulle part
non
là
et non
mauvaise haleine
et
[Applaudissements]
je
quelque chose
de la même manière
pour
le jour
sauf l'âge
solitaire
Oui
Vous ne verrez pas
ré
pour
aujourd'hui
amour
telam
Le Mexique ne sert à rien
de cette manière
le modéré
de la même manière
à présent
et maintenant oui non
ré
Voyons voir
ma vie
rien
en tant que tel
en cercle et seul
j'étais lucide de chaleur
arrive
non
comment lire
maintenant si vous voyez autre chose
Oui
frère
Oui oui
cours à gauche
sur cette piste
toute ma vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vient
Oui
et rien de plus
ré
parfois
et le canada
ré
Oui
bien sûr
Merci
et plus immédiat
et ici
à moi si
et à l'envers
ma mère
au jour le jour
Miranda
ré
[Applaudissements]
Adrien
Je ne savais pas s'il arriverait
ça ne me plaît pas
merde
pour moi
et asiatique
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une âme
ça peut être une lettre de cordoue
je ne sais pas pourquoi
cette exposition
la vie
L'âme
Qu'est-il arrivé
dans la zone
je
moi ça me plait
Alors
ce sont des saints
pourtant
je ne sais pas
c'est un avantage
bon
Je m'appelle
[Applaudissements]
de Lara
la maladie
la vie
si la pluie
Merde
Salut
je viens de me donner
plein de pièces
Merde
pour le mûrier
connu
lundi
par la force
à ma manière
De la marmite
[Applaudissements]
alors calme toi
et maintenant
Salut
c'est mauvais si le charbon de bois
la Floride doit s'améliorer
[Applaudissements]
et
parce que
[Applaudissements]
le jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évaluer
ici
[Applaudissements]
je
et
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose d'étrange
je
[Applaudissements]
et
pour
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
jour après jour
et en avant
il n'y avait rien
Imaginer
chaque jour
à présent
Paris
Oui
ici
pas du tout pas du tout pas mal du tout
bien que jamais du tout
Fête des Mères
Oui
je le ferai
dans ma vie
au but
maintenant oui merde tu ne reviendras pas
pour
et maintenant
pour plus
et pour les nouvelles pièces
titulaire
Oui
un m
je meurs
Oubliez
au-dessus d'eux
Aujourd'hui
la glace
dont oui mais néanmoins supporter
oui on peut idiot
mais non
[Applaudissements]
nous ne descendons pas
en outre
et
à partir de maintenant
Aujourd'hui
jorge arteaga en bois
et en avant
Galice
padille
et asiatique
ou oui
jour après jour
et
comme ci comme ça
et il en a été ainsi
alors j'ai dit
il a aussi dit
nous aussi
ma position
mieux
les militaires
la vie
bien
l'amérique que nous voulons
le chemin
quelques jours
et quelque chose de plus
de la zone
Je déteste
tous les jours
r
dans chaque forum
et tous
je n'ai jamais découvert
ce militaire
benítez tu ne sais pas vraiment tu sais
que tu m'as donné des radicaux
plus haute
et une autre fois
et sur terre ce ministère
déjà
[Applaudissements]
intello
Oh
ré
ou non
tous les jours
je ne sais pas
déjà
[Applaudissements]
de la morale
pour moi
[Applaudissements]
deux
Oh
[Applaudissements]
Remarque
Oui
[Applaudissements]
problèmes du système de santé
et
[Applaudissements]
Oui
c'était comme ça
Oh
Merci
je
en outre
le quartier
il ne se passe rien
Oh
mais ça
[Applaudissements]
Oh
En cela
C'est pourquoi nous n'obtenons pas les mêmes informations
bon
Oh
non
tu ne dis pas
en 2006
parfois
[Applaudissements]
Allez bien
séparé
mais non
mais la passion
à présent
Mme
[Applaudissements]
non
et
a savoir
dans le regard
c'est pas mal du tout
intello
non
en réalité
et
la vie
Oui
pour tous
pour moi
nous questionnons
et blessures
parler d'elle
[Applaudissements]
je
Oui
[Applaudissements]
mais
non
et
la décoration
m
bien
Oui
il pendentif
nous devrions
action
[Applaudissements]
mais pas
parfois
et parlons
Oui eux
ou s'ils devaient passer
après cette partie
comme je suis
[Applaudissements]
pour
et moi
très bien
Oui
[Applaudissements]
intello
ce matin
Oui
non
dans la vie
et n'importe qui d'autre
pour moi
Oui
vue
et le canada
mais non
dans l'annonce
une heure plus tard
avocat d'avance
J'ai déjà
l'adjoint au maire
le vent
à la charge
Oh
Salut
devant
ré
aider les autres
une partie de lui
[Applaudissements]
Oui ok
pour
le lieu
feuille
dans la mer
père
d'une autre manière
pendant le jeu
pendant la conversation
l'action
ma mère
c'est un art